widespread power outages are practically
guaranteed when this category 4
hurricane hits the Panhandle and moves
across the southeast more than 8,000
utility workers from Florida and other
states are on standby to put the power
back on after the storm passes through
Manuel Bojorquez is at a utility center
in Tallahassee minwell good morning good
morning typically this utility has a
hundred and twenty people working for it
today
they have 600 people either already out
in the field or standing by at
facilities like this one and we're told
they are prepared to work 16 hour shifts
until they get the power back on
Tallahassee is known for and very proud
of its tree canopy but that could be a
liability during a storm like Michael
this is not the only service provider in
this region Duke Energy estimates that
200,000 customers could be impacted by
power outages along Florida's panhandle
especially along the coast the company
says it could take days perhaps even
more than a week to fully restore power
just moments ago I spoke with Ron mogera
who is the general manager of the
utility here in Tallahassee about how
they prioritize getting power back on
what are you doing to get power back to
hospitals nursing homes assisted living
facilities those are priorities so as
soon as the wind dies down in the middle
of the night we'll look at what are
those part we have a priority list we
look at what are those priority
facilities that are out of service well
obviously we're anxious because of the
strength of the storm and having not
seen one like this before but we're also
prepared and a big important reminder
and warning from the utilities is for
anyone looking to use a portable
generator to get the power back on in
their homes they say please make sure
those are outside and not inside of your
house because that could lead to
dangerous and even deadly carbon
monoxide poisoning we've seen it happen
in storms before gale
all right men well that's very good
advice thank you